nous avons rendu compte de ces
événements dramatiques tout au long de
la soirée d'hier à travers des flashs
spéciaux jusqu'à une heure du matin
ce soir de nombreuses questions restent
pourtant posée nous allons tenter
maintenant d'y répondre pour cela dès
hier soir dès l'annoncé des premiers
incidents
nous avons envoyé des équipes de
reporter sur tous les points chauds pour
voir et surtout pour comprendre ce qui
se passait ce sont le reportage qui
nourriront l'essentiel de ce journal
mais d'abord le rappel des faits et une
première analyse avec bernard marck et
qu'ils avaient voulu voir un match de
football
ils sont morts étouffés frappé piétiner
écrasé certains poignardé leurs
meurtriers dean ce soir en famille
dégrisé fatigue et peut-être mais pas
coupable ni même inquiété les crimes
collectifs n'engage personne qu'ils
avaient franchi la manche les hooligans
pour se battre dans les tribunes d'un
stade on trouve toujours des adversaires
ils savent ça par expérience il y a en
plus un public témoin forcé de leur
violence c'est même cela qui les excite
le plus donner en spectacle leur
sauvagerie
les policiers absents au moment de
l'attaqué était bien là après mais
devant l'ampleur du désastre
débordé transformer en secouriste ou
défilant comme à la parade dissuasif
peut-être mais trop tard celui-ci médite
sur son impuissance et affiche son
désarroi
des eaux de leur monture cela contemple
la pelouse déserte
tournant le dos à la bataille et pendant
ce temps là les autres
l'immense majorité des cinquante cinq
mille spectateurs continuent leur fait
chante la gloire de leurs clubs
attendent pendant 1h30 le coup d'envoi
retardé prêt à vibrer prêt à oublier les
morts au moins pendant deux mi temps
21h40 ils vont jouer le drame ne leur a
pas coupé les jambes la bataille qui
continue n'entame pas leur lucidité
ce ne sera pas un grand match il y aura
un vainqueur et un vaincu
et puis le calme progressivement
retrouver les hooligans sont rentrés
chez eux et qui donc répondre à des 41
morts